l'orange couleur vive et stimulante que
ces cyclistes amateurs de 50 ans en
yeline ont choisi pour se donner un peu
d'énergie 30 km de parcours les
attendaiit pour rejoindre Paris ce
dimanche la grande convergence invitait
tous les Franciliens à rouler vers le
Louvre à l'occasion de la fête du vélo
quand je l'ai fait l'année dernière la
la pour remonter de Medon à Versailles
c'est c'est un peu vallonné donc ça
risque d'être un petit peu difficile le
retour mais à l'aller je pense que ça
ira parce que ça va DESC
à 10h le cortège se met donc en selle
une première pause s'impose à Versailles
où d'autres passionnés viennent grossir
les rangs du peloton yvelinois j'étais
parti pour pour prendre un peu de sport
prendre un peu de
liberté voilà de la nature un petit peu
quoi aujourd'hui 40 % des Français
déclarent faire du vélo régulièrement
plus qu'une mode la bicyclette est
devenue une véritable tendance pour
aller au travail ou au moins à la gare
la fête du vélo c'est donc aussi
l'occasion de défendre le droit des
cyclistes si on veut que le vélo se
développe et si on veut répondre aux
attentes de la population de des
personnes il faut il faut il faut
augmenter notamment les places de vélo
les places les parkings à vélo et il
faut que le les rues soit aménagé par
des limitations de vitesse pour
sécuriser les
déplacements à ce jour 85 km de piste
cyclable sont recensé dans toute
l'agglomération
cinquantinoise